ya hablamos de que la luz tiene
propiedades como de onda y considerando
nuestra experiencia de la vida cotidiana
consideramos a las ondas como una
perturbación que se propaga a través de
un medio hablamos de dejar caer una
piedra en el agua el agua es el medio y
vemos como la onda se propaga en ella
hablamos de ondas de sonido que es una
perturbación en el aire hablamos de una
onda que viaja a través de esta cuerda y
aquí el medio es la cuerda y en el siglo
19 era bastante razonable pensar que
bueno si la luz se comporta como una
onda es una perturbación que se va a
estar propagando en un medio y como no
podemos observar a este medio pues como
lo llamaremos vamos a llamarlo éter
lumínico así que la pregunta que se
hacían estas personas que hicieron esta
razonable suposición es de poder
detectar este éter lumínico se
preguntaban si podían validar la
existencia de este éter lumínico y aquí
la idea clave es pensar que nosotros nos
estamos moviendo con
y rapidez en comparación de este test
lumínico como sabemos esto bueno tenemos
que recordar y este planeta está rotando
no solo sobre su eje sino también
alrededor del sol imaginemos que este es
el sol y por aquí está la tierra
este es un dibujo aproximado y la tierra
está rotando alrededor del sol más o
menos así y nuestro planeta está rotando
alrededor del sol aproximadamente 30
kilómetros por segundo y para nuestros
estándares cotidianos esto es bastante
rápido pero no termina ahí ya que el sol
se está moviendo alrededor del centro de
la galaxia y bueno aunque ésta no es una
imagen de la vía láctea obviamente no
hemos viajado tan lejos de ella como
para poder verla así pero si imaginamos
que el sol se encuentra aquí se va a
estar moviendo más o menos alrededor del
centro de la galaxia
a una velocidad aproximada de 200
kilómetros km por segundo esto es
alrededor del centro de la galaxia de la
vía láctea y la misma galaxia se está
moviendo también y aunque no conocemos
nuestra orientación en relación al éter
sabemos que nos estamos moviendo
constantemente nos estamos moviendo en
estos patrones orbitales si existiera
algún tipo de éter domínico voy a
dibujar estas líneas así representando
el éter nosotros debemos estar nos
moviendo en relación a este eterno min y
ccoo las probabilidades de que nosotros
estuviéramos estáticos con respecto al
éter son muy cercanas a cero si
estuviéramos estacionarios en relación
al éter por ejemplo en este punto como
la tierra se está moviendo y está
rotando al llegar a este punto ya no
estaríamos estacionarios con respecto al
éter
esto es solo considerando la órbita de
la tierra alrededor del sol esto sin
duda se cumple con mayor razón si
pensamos en el movimiento del sistema
solar alrededor del centro de la galaxia
o incluso el movimiento de la propia
galaxia así que deberíamos estarnos
moviendo en relación con el éter o el
éter debe de estarse moviendo en
relación a nosotros por lo que nosotros
deberíamos de detectar lo que se llama
el viento de test
ya que se debe de estar moviendo en
relación a nosotros pero nos preguntamos
si es que esto existe y si lo podemos
detectar bueno pensemos en otros medios
que se mueven en relación a nosotros
imaginemos que nos encontramos en una
isla que se encuentra a la mitad de una
corriente y estas son las orillas de esa
corriente y como es un tipo de corriente
el agua se va a estar moviendo en cierta
dirección digamos que se está moviendo
en esta dirección este es mi medio y
ahora vamos a hacer que una onda se
propague en este medio si yo tomara una
piedra y la dejara caer por acá qué va a
pasar pues la onda se va a propagar más
rápido hacia la izquierda que hacia la
derecha y esto viene de nuestra
experiencia cotidiana porque en el medio
se está moviendo y en este caso el medio
se está moviendo más rápido hacia la
izquierda así que conforme el medio se
mueve y la onda se propaga en ese medio
se propagara más rápidamente hacia la
izquierda que hacia la derecha digamos
que a pocos momentos de que lanzamos la
piedra la onda se propaga hacia acá
hacia la derecha y se propaga hasta acá
hacia la izquierda así que va a ser más
o menos así y después de que pasa un
poco más de tiempo esta onda podría
verse más o menos
así por lo que como podemos ver en este
ejemplo de la corriente nuestra onda se
va a propagar más rápidamente en la
dirección de la corriente o en la
dirección hacia dónde va el medio de
forma similar si tenemos este viento de
éter oeste e ter lumínico es el medio en
donde se propaga la luz ya que suponemos
que la luz es una perturbación en este
medio
si este medio oeste viento tuviera una
rapidez que vamos a llamar no se s
si trataremos de propagar la luz en esta
dirección y la comparamos contra esta
dirección deberemos notar que la luz va
mucho más rápidamente hacia esta
dirección que hacia esta otra ya que
esta dirección coincide con la del
movimiento del éter y está coincidiendo
con la dirección en la que se está
moviendo el medio al menos comparándolo
con nosotros y si la luz se propaga en
dirección opuesta a la del medio aún
cuando se esté propagando en el éter con
la misma velocidad el éter o el medio se
va a estar moviendo en la otra dirección
así que la luz con base en nuestro
entendimiento del universo en el siglo
19 esta luz debería a parecernos más
lenta por lo que ustedes se pueden
imaginar que las personas empezaron a
preguntarse bueno a lo mejor podemos
medir la luz propagándose en diferentes
direcciones y podemos ver si con
relación a nosotros observamos alguna
diferencia en la velocidad de la luz
el problema aquí es que la luz es
tremendamente rápida y a mediados del
siglo 19 los instrumentos de los que
disponemos para medir la luz pues no
eran muy precisos que digamos nosotros
ahora sabemos que la velocidad de la luz
es aproximadamente igual a 300.000
kilómetros por segundo y a mediados del
siglo 19
no teníamos instrumentos que pudieran
medir estas velocidades con mucha
precisión especialmente porque el éter
mismo aunque nosotros digamos que nos
movemos a alrededor del sol a 30
kilómetros por segundo o alrededor de la
galaxia a 200 kilómetros por segundo
estas velocidades van a ser muy pequeñas
comparadas con la de la luz así que si
no tenemos mucha precisión para poder
medir este tipo de velocidades como la
velocidad de la luz en estas direcciones
y suponiendo que la velocidad del éter
es mucho más lenta en comparación con la
de la luz pues con las herramientas de
mediados del siglo 19 no vamos a poder
medir este viento de éter si es que éste
existe y esto nos lleva al famoso
experimento mickelson morly ya que ellos
no trataron de medir directamente la
velocidad de la luz en una dirección o
en la otra
de esto ellos pensaron en separar la luz
en dos direcciones diferentes para
después recombinarlas y observar el
patrón de interferencia y si en las
diferentes direcciones la luz viaja con
diferente velocidad entonces veremos
diferentes patrones de interferencia y
eso es lo que vamos a explicar en el
siguiente vídeo